how's it going everybody
this is International Master Daniel
wrench this is chest comm and this is
the everything you need to know video
series here today with the second
installment on the middlegame stage or
how tactics and strategy come together
in a chess game tactics and strategy to
find every specific move that is made
within a chess game with the term tactic
being used to describe every capture or
every threat of capture you can make in
a chess game or your opponent can make
and strategy being the term that
describes just about every other move
every long-term thought every deep plan
that you can develop every long-term
weakness that you or your opponent have
in your position is a strategical
weakness or positional weakness and
we're going to talk about how strategy
and tactics come together and how they
work together and you better buckle up
because in the next 15 minutes we're
going to jam-packed so much information
into this video it's going to move fast
it's going to be a bumpy ride
but I'm going to guarantee you results
that will change your chest life because
chess is 90% tactics it's going to make
up for the majority of this video and
it's where we're going to start we use
that term to describe chess as being 90%
tactics because every game whether at
the lowest level or highest level must
eventually be decided by a tactic some
sort of threat somebody missed the
threat by their opponent of some kind in
order to lose a chess game so tactics in
that sense make up for 90% of the
critical moments of chess because if you
blunder you lose it's that simple so
with that said we don't really need to
tell you why it's important to win your
opponent's pieces we all know that the
ultimate goal of the game is to check my
data me King so informing you that you
should count attackers and defenders try
to capture your opponent's pieces
shouldn't be new information to you nor
should it be that you should try to
prevent your opponent from doing
relatively the same thing but what we
like to do is show you the basic and
critical tactical patterns you should be
aware of when you play your games now
these are the most fundamental because
we can't fit everything into this small
video what we can do is tell you that
every tactical pattern even the most
advanced are in some ways
our advanced versions that are just
built on top of these fundamental and
critical themes that we're going to show
you here today so let's go ahead and
jump right in with the first tactical
pattern that being the double attack or
fork a double attack is arguably the
most common type of tactical pattern
that occurs in a chess game essentially
the principle is simple you move one
piece to attack two enemy pieces at the
same time thus leaving your opponent and
sometimes an impossible situation when
it comes to defending both pieces here
we see a very simple version a very
commonly used version to highlight the
principle of a double attack the white
rook moves to f7 attacking both the
knight and the bishop at one time and
white will win material shortly a fork
is the term used to describe a double
attack by either the knight or the pawn
here we see two forks in action with the
knight having the ability to move Knight
to e7 check for King the king and queen
as well as we see the pawn with the
ability to move forward forking the two
knights by definition a double attack or
a fork only works if you're attacking
two pieces that cannot capture you back
for example if we replace the Queen on
c8 with a knight it would not be
possible for this Knight to move to e7
and fork the King and Knight as he would
simply be recaptured and so in summary a
double attack is the act of moving one
piece to attack at least two enemy
pieces at one time with the fork being a
term we use to describe a double attack
by either the knight or the pawn
arguably the second most common type of
tactical pattern or theme that can occur
in a chess game would be a pin a pin is
the act of attacking an enemy piece
however that piece either cannot move or
does not wish to move for fear of losing
a more valuable piece the first type of
pin is known as an absolute pin that
would be when a piece is pinned to the
king for it is absolutely illegal for
that piece to move we see that the
Bishop on b5 is also applying an
absolute pin to the rook the second type
of pin that can occur in a chess game
known as a relative pin is on display
here we see the bishop attacking the
knight on f6
and though that night might like to move
under certain circumstances it would be
ill-advised to do so as long as there is
a queen
standing behind it though it is not
illegal for the pinned piece to move in
a relative pin it is normally
going to happen because moving the
lesser value piece would immediately
result in the loss of a greater value
piece a relative pin can also be a very
powerful tool though it is not as
forcing of a tactic as an absolute pin
to quickly show you one practical
example where a relative pin can occur
very early on in a chess game we can
review the Queen's Gambit decline which
is an opening we quickly went over and
everything you need to know video about
the opening stage with both sides
developing their pieces to either attack
and defend the pressure point on d5
white applies a relative pin as early as
move four with the sole purpose of
putting pressure on the key knight that
guards the center moving on our next
tactical pattern or theme of the
discussion is known as the opposite of
the pin that being the skewer the skewer
is the act of attacking a more valuable
enemy piece so that when that piece
moves you can win or capture whatever
piece is behind it whether that be an
equal or lesser valued piece in this
position we see that both white and
black have the ability to skewer the
opponent depending on whose move it was
with both sides moving the book over to
check the king and after that King is
forced to a safe square the rook would
remain on free for the opponent to
capture to see it in action white moves
over and takes the free piece a skewer
can also occur by attacking the Queen
and then taking whatever piece remains
undefended after the Queen must find
safety though it is arguably not as
forcing of a tactic as it is to attack
the King and give check you see that it
can be just as powerful to attack the
Queen as either she must be lost for a
lesser valued rook or find safety and
allow the worse rook takes e8 checkmate
one final very common type of skewer
occurs at the end of a pawn race with
both sides pushing their pawns to
promote toward a queen here we see that
though Black has won the race with an
awkward King white is able to promote
and immediately apply a skewer along the
diagonal winning the undefended piece
behind it it should be noted that only
the long-range pieces being the Queen's
rooks and bishops are capable of
applying pins or skewers let's move on
we now already begin to see tactical
patterns repeat themselves at least in
some small manner here we're learning
the discovered attack or
check in this position white has the
ability to move this Bishop unleashing a
check by the rook on d1 to the King on
d8 and at the same time applying an
attack to the Queen by definition this
could be known as a double attack just
like the previous example we've already
given however it's a more advanced
version of the same type of theme we are
attacking two pieces at once but we've
only been able to do so in this manner
because we unleash the attack of another
a discovery is the act of moving one of
your own pieces to unleash a piece that
otherwise would not be attacking the
enemy the most powerful type of
discovery would be a double attack as
you can see here that moving the bishop
to any random square would also be a
discovered check however finding the
most valuable square for the bishop that
being one that attacks the enemy queen
makes perfect sense a discovered check
or a discovered double attack is one of
the most powerful types of tactics you
can play in chess and if a discovered
attack or a discovered check is one of
the most powerful types of attacks or
tactics you can play in chess you could
argue that discovered double check is
the most powerful move possible in any
given chess game here this position is
the Venus flytrap one of the most famous
mating nets known in a chess game white
begins by playing Knight to f7 check and
after the King moves to g8 the most
important part of why we're showing this
example it becomes clear the knight
moves to h6 releasing check on the King
what should be noted is that both the
Queen and the knight are possible
captures for black however it is
impossible to capture two pieces at once
so despite the fact that both of white's
pieces are hanging per se black is
unable to do anything but move the King
a double check is the most powerful move
in chess because it leaves the King to
his own device as always he's unable to
move to f8 because of checkmate on f7
and quickly if he moves to h8 we see the
climax of the Venus flytrap mating net
with white sacrificing the Queen and
delivering a smother checkmate on f7
again the main point of this is not how
practical in nature
the theme is nor is it really even the
mating net the idea is to show you how
powerful the act of playing a discovered
attack or a discovered check tactic can
be
with the double check being the most
powerful form of a discovered attack
again we see it end in blacks demise and
on that note of witnessing one of our
tactical patterns or themes for today
and in a mating net pattern or theme as
we can see here with the smothered mate
I'd like to show you two other very
common types of checkmate patterns that
wouldn't necessarily be classified as a
tactical pattern but are nonetheless
critical enough and important enough for
us to get across in today's video the
first checkmate pattern to follow the
smothered mate that we just saw will be
the support mate a support made by
definition is the act of moving your
queen up close and personal with the
enemy king to give checkmate where the
Queen finds herself supported by one
other piece of the same color
here we see arguably the most common
type of support mate with the Queen
giving checkmate supported by her own
king let's use this as a second example
of a support mate with the Queen coming
in to checkmate the enemy king protected
by the lone minor piece the knight with
the third perhaps more practical version
of support made occurring here with the
White Queen capturing an enemy pawn
supported for checkmate by the lone
minor piece our final extremely common
type of checkmate pattern under
discussion in today's video is the back
rank checkmate the background checkmate
is often the climax of many different
types of combination and tactical ideas
that you can play in a chess game and it
occurs on either the 8th or first rank
depending on which King is being
checkmated when the enemy king is
attacked by a lateral piece either the
brook or queen and the king is unable to
escape due to the fact that he's blocked
in or imprisoned by his own pawns a back
rank checkmate can be easily avoided by
a simple pawn push however in many
complex games often a player does not
have time to make such a move so we see
the back rank as a common weakness and
the subject of many different types of
checkmate combinations in conclusion
that wraps up the tactical themed and
checkmate pattern portion of this video
strategy was perhaps defined best by
former world champion and father of the
Soviet chess school Mikhail Botvinnik
when he said tactics are the servant of
strategy what he meant precisely is that
though
tactics make up for 90% of chess and you
will need to use tactics in every
critical moment you will receive good
tactics by understanding the strategical
nature and the long-term features of
every position you play like discussing
all the tactical themes it would be
impossible for us to lay out every
strategical concept within the remaining
few minutes of this video so instead
we'd like to point out what you need to
be aware of when you play your games as
far as what the long-term and basic
strategical features are of just about
every chess game you play to start out
let's review something we talked about
in the first video every one of your
pieces has a starting value the rook
being five knights and bishops three and
the queen being worth nine however as
you develop your pieces and activate
them onto better squares the value of
those pieces may or may not go up and
down in nature so your general goal in
the beginning of the game your first
step toward having good strategy is to
develop your pieces into the center as
we pointed out all of your pieces will
do better when they are on their most
active squares and active pieces lead to
good tactics so your first strategical
tip is a very general one and it
requires no movement of the board put
your pieces on good squares particularly
as discuss the center is arguably the
best place for all of your pieces and
once your pieces are put in the center
there is typically two factors two lists
of criteria that you can weigh to decide
on the value of your pieces how many
squares does the piece of tax last
control and is the piece safe this being
a great example of two pieces that
started out on equal footing both value
to three points though the knight is
clearly the superior piece in this
situation having dominated the center
and here would be a second example of
two pieces that would start out of equal
value though the white rook having
dominated the seventh rank targeting all
of blacks pawns potentially and keeping
the King at bay is clearly the superior
piece to the black rook on f8
essentially if the piece is perfectly
safe and controls up to its maximum
number of squares you have that piece on
its best square you're executing good
piece strategy our final piece of
fundamental strategical device has to do
with making you aware of long-term
positional planning and this abstract
position we highlight simply three types
of pawn weaknesses that you should be
aware of in your own
game's first double pawns which are weak
for two reasons they cannot protect each
other and they stand in each other's way
thus preventing progress secondly an
isolated pawn which is weak because it
has no brother pawns no pawns of the
same color on either of the adjacent
files and finally backward pawns which
are weak due to the fact that they
cannot move forward one move
for obvious reasons nor can they move
forward two moves because of fear of
bumpass on in this situation the white
pawn on g5 holds back both of blacks
ponds that are backward on h7 and f7 in
review chess is 90% tactics and you need
to know these fundamental tactical
patterns in order to have success in
your chess games if any of these
patterns remain unclear please back up
and review those segments of the video
the basic checkmate patterns often occur
at the end or as the climax of many
tactical combinations you need to be
aware of these three tactics are the
servant of strategy and good pieces lead
to good tactics please be aware that
pawns will also help you in developing
long-term strategical plans everything
you need to know about tactics and
strategy is now complete we hope you
enjoyed this video and we will see you
around on chess calm
you